so I'm not sure how much time I'm gonna
have at the end here but I just want to
remind you that we have the heads up
finals coming up very quickly after this
and of course we will be back tomorrow
for the beginning of day two
how many will be broadcast it live at 12
30 by the Norwegians we'll be on a bit
more of a delight doing it in English
players will have their cards in the air
at noon players can still enter late
register before the start of day two
this is a freeze out event so players
that you have seen get eliminated both
during yesterday's day 1A and today's
day 1B will not be able to get back in
the action this is a pure poker event
poker as it should be
there's nothing worse when you eliminate
an amazing player and then you see them
back deep in an event only to take your
Chips later
I love how in this Norwegian
Championship Main Event once you're out
you can't get back in again
it's not about generating as much rake
up as possible it's about being as
player friendly as possible
and meanwhile we may see Magnus Carlson
shipping up at the end of the day
getting no love gets back to half a
starting stack